Nói 5 tháng 11, chùi chia hội gỡi trị bến chính phủ với các địa phương thằng chiến năm 2019,
thu tướng phạm mình chính yêu cầu bộ nội vụ xây dựng ghế hoạch.
Hương dẫn đánh giá cán mộ hàng tháng, hàng quyết, hàng năm đời với cán mộ thuộc dễn chính phủ của anh.
Má cáo tại hội gỡ, bố trường mở vụ phạm thị thách trả cho biết sau 3 thằng chiến hai mô hình chính quyền địa phương 2 cấp.
Hếu qua quản chỉ được năng lên, đối ngũ cán mộ thị ứng tốt hơn,
dài gưỡi thu tục thành chính chuyển biên só.
Tuy nhiên, con hạn chỉ về năng lực, chắc nghiệp tính chủ động ở cấp sát,
bình quân mỗi sạch có khoảng 4.5 cắn mộ công trước trong đó khoảng 60% dắt ứng yêu cầu.
Bực phân cấp, phân quyền còn vương mắc, hạt tăng công nghệ thông viên chủ động bộ,
chơi lên thông, chi trả chế độ theo nghị định 1,5 bẩy mấy tám và sáo mới bẩy con chậm.
Thưa ra tới, bố nội vụ xế ra sóa pháp lợt, tăng cường vỗ trợ, đào tạo,
tức tục tăng cường cắn mộ cấp tình về cơ sở,
nấu tức hạt tăng số và sớm hình thành đơn vị sửa nghiệp cùng ứng sịch vụ công ở cấp sát.